Wow the ultimate payback of some kind
haha late for the school bus
how early incident y'all right kids
y'all right back there you doing okay
Santa [ __ ] motherland we did not have
Santa will do poor at school kids get
the [ __ ] out of my bus kill just now I
have to it I have to ask hot chocky but
to put you why yeah what the hell
that doesn't even make any sense what is
those kill yourself kill yourself well
I'm I'm I'm extremely good at killing
myself wait a minute am I actually
supposed to do this wait a min hang on
well fall down fall down of doom ha ha
again what are you doing hey there we go
we oh wait what
almost good hahaha
slum Oakwood but I didn't ever get to do
anything what that was a slow mo Wow
downfall
I'm guessing it's cuz we fall down not
falling another one were my kids were my
nubile young kids oh oh this is the ball
feeder machine we'll both get to it
grabber I'm sorry that last part was far
too obscene to be viewed by the public
but I didn't saturate because I don't
believe in that sort of crap huh oh here
we go
ah poacher ski [ __ ] and let's try this
again let's try this again with a little
less failure on my part one last try
with not killing myself which I am very
good at deed what just don't press
anything well well if I don't want to
play by your rules
oh what's this I'm pressing something I
pressed um what's gonna happen test your
neck I love these ones
what bottle run bottle run epic [ __ ]
okay bottle run epic and super skills oh
come on oh my god I'm not gonna make it
I'm not gonna make it what now I got
that [ __ ] come on I've never lost a
bobble run in my life I'm not gonna
start now I'm not gonna let that thing
there's not enough okay come on come on
come on come on it's impossible it's
impossible it's impossible it's
impossible it's impossible I can't
finish it impossible I there's this ball
this ball I got it with my crotch yeah
Nord power the longest ball ride ever
Oh
Oh purple rope swing wait a minute this
is quite different than the other rope
swing grab on son grab on let go
Sean I care so much
oh go course secret finish wait a minute
it says just kidding down there I think
it's real
I want to believe what Oh splits yes
100% impossible whoop got that out of
the way now it's just face roll into
victory here Biscay whoop Ski Mountain
ski this ski this ski I've turned into a
swastika kill JB Schwartzberg what does
everybody have so much against Justin
Bieber two headed demon
wait what ha suck it fans
I hate fans fans are the worst in the
world
ha ha ha I kill jamie's personal wizard
how cool if I wear ski
I missed hanging Jabir ski are just too
strong for it ha ba skate
what he's got about to go what I work
I'm continued play
okay-dokey neon rainbow Pogo yan rainbow
Pogo uh what a failure
oh yeah back oh there's no road back
there I've lost my pogo boom ohh
that was stupid press space ok
stupid little kids don't call me down
I'm using my fat to sample just
everybody I'm judging bad doctor coach
jiggle-jiggle-jiggle [ __ ] oh alright
cuz just just do it I can't take it
anymore kids I can't take it anymore
hey I'm okay life is worth living again
Alex Larson battle
but wait a minute we're not supposed to
burn up or the plan run ah love some
extreme food in action oh oh oh
best cake give me all my nards yes I
lost some dead weight but that's alright
old western boots
what I what why huh
push it if you want what lose the point
of that it's an even longer model run
time to my failure as a bottle run
champion go great yeah I'm glass breaker
I hate glass breaks Oh
nor are you kids we've been through a
lot together it's time for a little R &
R by R&R I mean Brahman more wrong God
play Kenneth click on Wow death machine
3 pool better how do I go wait how do I
go
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you liked what
you saw and you want to see more why not
subscribe to my channel want to help the
channel grow
leave a like add it to your favorites or
share it with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video